investigators say they are closer to
solving the mystery of who murdered a
federal prosecutor more than 16 years
ago but they need the public's help
assistant US attorney Tom Wales was shot
and killed in his Washington state home
in 2001 officials believe there are
people who know critical information
that could help solve the case they
increased the reward money to more than
one and a half million dollars Tony de
copal is following the investigation
Tony good morning good morning and what
an investigation it is Tom Wales was
targeted some say because of his job and
if that is true he would be the first
and only US attorney killed in the line
of duty the case has never gone cold and
the new reward may be a sign that
investigators believe they're getting
closer to the truth on a chilly October
night in 2001 Tom Wales was home sitting
in his basement office when a gunman
shot multiple rounds through the window
Wales was an 18 year veteran of the US
Attorney's Office in Seattle the killer
was familiar with Tom's property and his
work habits the shooter was careful to
avoid setting off floodlights attached
to the yards motion detectors leading
investigators to believe it was a
carefully planned execution more than 16
years later the killer is still at large
and the case was recently the subject of
a five-part podcast they say it was the
perfect murder
but I'm not buying it investigators
aren't buying it either they came
together Wednesday in a Seattle
conference room named for the fallen US
Attorney asking the public to help solve
the case we have a lot of investigative
theories right now we have several that
we're very fond of and we need more
information I think they have have
people identified that they think are
the perpetrators John McKay took over as
the US attorney in Seattle
shortly after Wales was killed they're
waiting for someone in their circles to
come forward and give them maybe the the
last couple of pieces that will push
them over the finish line the reward for
information in the case has been raised
from up to 1 million to more than one
and a half million dollars after
previous leads failed early on
investigators identified a suspect a
commercial airline pilot who denied any
involvement and was never charged
through bullet casings they say they
identified the weapon
but they apparently never found it Wales
his daughter suggests her father's
duties as a prosecutor might have played
a role in his murder if a federal
prosecutor can be brutally murdered for
carrying out his prosecutorial duties
the law enforcement and judicial
processes that keep all of us safe are
fundamentally compromised an indication
of how committed Wales as former
colleagues are in solving this case they
are among those who open their wallets
to increase the reward by more than a
half million dollars and another
indication is that the FBI has generated
more than 2,000 sub files on this case
each one an individual line of inquiry
it's important to solve it yeah
important to solve it thank you Tony
thank you very much Tony